siguen los contagios al alza en china a
pesar de los confinamientos se ha
informado de 700 casos diarios en la
cifra más alta en dos meses hay dos
focos principales el primero es en la
remota y montañosa provincia de gansú en
su capital and joe sus casi cuatro
millones de habitantes llevan una semana
encerrados el otro es en la otra punta
del país en la costa oriental ahí ha
sido confinada beihai es un célebre
destino turístico lo que ha provocado
que miles de visitantes queden atrapados
sin poder salir shanghai ha detectado 23
casos hoy son 6 más que el día anterior
así que se han ordenado test masivos en
12 de los 16 distritos china es la única
gran economía del mundo que sigue
aferraba a la política de 'cero cobit
que incluye el confinamiento costes y
cierre de fronteras la factura quedó
clara con los recientes datos de
crecimiento económico del segundo
trimestre apenas creció un 0,4 por
ciento es la cifra más baja desde que el
cobach surgiera dos años y medio atrás
los expertos dudan de que china va a
alcanzar el pronóstico oficial del 5,5
por ciento anual porque para ello
exigiría un acelerón tremendo en la
segunda parte del año y para ello sería
necesario a su vez que china jubilar a
su política de 'cero covite quien ha
repetido en las últimas semanas que unas
cuantas décimas menos de pib son menos
importantes que la vida y la salud de su
población